we got a packed house today packed house
strong crew Becky Rodriguez Braga gay
he's a bailar Christine Peggy Rory again
take photo arty huh I like to piece on
my camera to make sure it's a grip I -
peed on my hand to make sure I don't get
a grip on the camera I get a grip on the
camera I don't drop the camera in the
agua I don't drop the camera in the soda
pop I don't know the yay today or the
NRA or they you are eat dog I love what
he does it's garbage what it's made for
assholes what the final nostra hardline
that you drink it I didn't say anything
bad if I said I liked it and then you
had to be a dick yeah but you came like
I liked it like you say hey so watch
your mouth from here on out I like it so
watch your mouth and so hey hey that's a
family friend we were all laugh
I said where he doesn't un you say
[Music]
it's the bonfire coming since already a
Sirius XM 95 quarry you do whatever you
gotta do Corey you're a good man though
just making that move of turning out of
the lights a little bit uh whatever you
guys need me to work with Mike condoms
don't pop my Peas
hell yeah big Jay oakerson that handsome
sumbitch with much more depth than just
looks Thank You Janis odor Jacobs doing
a weird thing on the wall over there
what the hell wasn't happen are you
trying to be a bad boy and hey now
alternate Mel Gibson your shoulder back
in the place Oh were you lethal weapon
in it I was trying where did you pop
your shoulder up
no let's just turn this what we doing
you want to do the thing where we link
arms and I bend over and you go up on my
back gonna be awesome
join me to walk on your back do you want
Dan and walk on your back I just found
out I'm steppin on the scales at 220 so
I'll recorrect Christine he'll get on my
back crack's rate world class what if
you broke Jacob
we just gotta he'll haul of his body I
learned from a licensed person I could
do it good
whoo what kind of license my
ex-mother-in-law okay yeah look what she
does she did she does realignments yeah
right is it Bella's ear right that's
what she does I don't know if it works I
was asking you on the microphone there
your glory hound off the mic Mama's on
the mic she's a licensed massage
therapist right yeah okay so she did
teach you so shiny times in her life was
she definitely approached with like
handy
yeah like so thanks for the massage now
you flop your towel off and you go do
that
female masseuses have to probably see so
much hard dick that they don't want to
say like I'm trying to help you heal sir
you have a shoulder tear stop putting
your hand on your I have a show is
wondering if you could tear something
else up just look at it a little bit you
know look at it yeah today's and that's
just their shift that's like the coal
mining for women please any accent
on you like
well you have to time to go grab hot
coals burn hands who was the baseball
player that pissed on their hands they
give him Callas who was that that was it
there was a baseball player that
famously peed on his hands too callosum
really for holding the bat does that
work I don't know man let's try why
don't you give it a shot yeah oh yeah
dude it says gives you the radio yeah I
don't know who it is come in everyone's
laughing when I go Dan I've been peeing
on my hand that's not him it's a famous
baseball player like a reliever from the
70s from Boston no it's uh I think he's
Cuban and he was on the expose
there's anybody with us on the cruise
ship that was dumb enough that we could
have convinced them before we go into
the ocean like if you don't want to get
like pressure sickness yeah do you have
to drink your own pee is there anybody
we could have got to do that ah probably
there's no way to look it up well there
is no internet there are some those
bracelets mm-hmm they stop queasiness
which i think is just placebo I think
it's just placebo - I feel good yet John
McEnroe bans all of a sudden about John
McEnroe
never dizzy never queasy never queasy
guys always unstable feet that's why he
can return to serve like a
that guy's on solid ground like I send
that 112 mile or at you hit in windy
conditions I'll it oh I can trip
myself and still return the serve I
never have both sickness trouble and I
force it salut that's who it is he's not
a high pollen no what is he Dominicans
Moises Alou used to pee on his hands
instead of having batting gloves was his
birthday party era of me watching
baseball he's Dominican uh yeah they're
all Dominican Dan there's some Cuban huh
there's some Cuban players
if you see ones that are frustrated to
be wearing shoes the Dominican
Thank You black lo he revealed the drink
good sweetie Hey
I try to play big ball the ball by my
feet I try to blend my ball he says
you're a Dominican is the upswing I try
to play my ball and you make me worry
shoe I put this back on the bus so he
stay I pee on my hands so he brought
this I takes a piece on my head
Oh let my head get rough the goddess
moistened I heard the bat better he's
had the bye bye her he says he he sounds
like a terrible teammate cuz he used to
not only pee on his hands he was always
into high-fives hey high-five it like a
so bitchy was Megan the high-five and
pranking teammates while they were
sleeping in the locker room I'm not fall
five five what's the big deal I pee on
my hand Oh give him better money back I
want me to hold your plate of food I
have a good grade
you want half of my sandwich oh yeah I
see you looking at hey Vega breathe God
take this out with you ok Moises stop
peeing on your hands I would do it in
front of people I could never play on a
team with yeah you could if he was
hitting 365 I'd go over to it like it
was a like a natural spring and back to
be some of that Moises yeah he said is
purified by kidneys this war wow man
someone had a spare kiss for lunch
you know how tougher my hands gonna be
when it's another dudes piss
I know but Mickey might be another
that's dangerous that dangerous game
make sure is my gaming you're dancing
you're walking it very die row why why
is this just written down I love wake up
wake up is evil Jacob is the Wario for
Jacob he loves it wake up
this is diabolical laugh with the
sebastian ticket i was curly mustache
look at this
someone's gonna make it evil Jacob
online you have to wake up the evil
Jacob
look this evil hand right you can tell
it says lose Facebook's key I'm so
excited
loose miser lose scam Facebook chick
okay my loose facebook scam which means
yet again old thumbs over here
whole swipey Swiper to this wobbly
wobbly leg gazelle he's getting caught
by every predator out there I mean Jesus
Christ he is you're out there broads got
a deep down in his his palms hello do
you want to explain yourself hang on
I'll be honestly I'll shut up for the
next four minutes listen to the whole
song I'll pee on my hands think I'm
afraid you little cysts on my hands here
pull this thing out alright you guys
give me some first off all right I'm
thinking about it don't look at me I'm
gonna put my hand my glass of water
right here Jacob get in this right here
Christina tell me you won't have a
better Mouse grip Oh Who am I kidding
man probably bathe in this stuff yeah Oh
Christine showers in it yeah Christine
just has an exterior skeleton of piss
yeah yeah eight times for water
Eaton's for the urine yeah seems like a
night yeah she gets a clear shower and
the day golden shower in the evening man
Becky own and I should start peeing on
each other you know I don't know this is
exactly what Peter Cetera had in mind he
penned this song yeah men share page
news well he's worried he's gonna lose
her because he's presented now that he's
into peeing yeah and she's walking out
the door but she's like hmm you know she
grabs the doorknob and her hand slips
will fight yeah he lets go huh
and then he offers up he points down to
his penis okay and he starts a nice
thick stream and while he's going she
reaches down and gets her hands in it
grabs the doorknob turns it on the first
try
opens it looks out looks back at him
closes the door and goes and
it's 350 and her softball league that
year it's unbelievable because that grip
that air time goddamn grip they're tight
it's like wearing an Eastern glove it's
like back in the 8th yeah he's putting
tar on your back it's got a tar drip
because of his piss Lou how did you get
scammed by a Jenna on Facebook know what
also a Jetta I'll be buying a jet are
you it are you giving a teenage girl Kim
senior president I didn't know you were
an Applebee's hostess are you girls
going to the beach or just dancing no
guys no guys we're just dancing oh my
god let me guess you got to go smoke one
of your new port lights around the
corner and steam off are you gonna beach
town shopping yeah are you GU your
friends gonna ride around with the top
down and wearing oversized sunglasses
just gonna blare your sister Hazel
driver hey it's me Lou me the gals are
gonna head out
girls day I mean a real girls day no
guys put the phones away we're gonna eat
what we want buy what we want come on
the future is feminine Oh girls promise
me let's all buy these best friend
pendants it breaks in four ways you
bitch those jeans look perfect on we're
going to the Teaneck more is it a little
tawdry sure but you know it's Friday Lou
why did you were you just in the market
for a car are you trying to buy a car I
enjoyed the bus a lot I swear to God
come on buddy it just presented itself
this idea that somebody posted on our
hometown group you know those of us from
the same town yeah you're in a Facebook
group from your hometown you are to
community come on Facebook don't go on
it but you're aren't no he's on a group
no I know I'm not that's like it's a
crazy
he's a planner gonna pull from yeah near
Teaneck well you don't have a
Teaneck adjacent my employer groups on
Facebook I am but I don't that was like
the first week of Facebook I don't know
anything literally I'd say I never
looked at them I've never gone I found
out I was like the president of like a
local Aurora thing where I'm like what's
what's Happ swith Dan Soder you see me
doing videos hello it's up guys this
week in Aurora at America's Bar and
Grill on Iliff you get chicken wings
again for 5 cents shout out to the all
the alumni from the rusty Wolfe high
school that you went to Smoky Hill yeah
rusty what did I sell buffs rusty hook
Smoky Hill rusty wolf hey man
his route said the dildo bike factory so
hard living you come out of work and
then go over and help your old man build
dildo bikes Snell Polly retired helping
put the on the seats that's like
putting a star on a Christmas tree every
day he'd hand you a wrench in your left
hand take a hot piss in your right hand
he said son ride the bike does it fit
real tight I was a daddy's boy
you're loose like your mom I'm trying to
calibrate this thing I'm making it for
people who are size Queen to tack on
your size Queen has to be one of us
emasculating things if I had a kid and I
got into a fight with a might like a 13
year old son am son your buttholes
chewing that thing right up oh no no no
I'm sorry pac-man Jesus Christ what are
you a Python what was going on why are
you buying a Jetta were you gonna drive
a fourteen-year-old girl to get an
abortion
are you following Dave Matthews Band on
the road oh wow it's got good gas
mileage and a bars dream all the
prosperous right with low mileage it
still smells like girl in a boat real
and real inside senses and dewlap
not a chance boys we gonna roll down
Windows yeah Facebook scam what did it
say what year is it Lou Oh doesn't eat
your 2008 Jetta at 11 years old so you
see it a group and somebody's somebody
posted uh this is for my sister she
doesn't have Facebook
her email which I did and she said you
gotta buy it off of ebay if you want it
off from me and you can only pay an ebay
gift cards that's where the suspect is
well the whole thing was just a gay
check to see what guys were gonna
respond to it also also you got to go on
Amazon and pick your favorite lip gloss
here's a whole thing I had to do then I
had to go save my favorite pattern of
dress my favorite bracelet link I had to
email her a seductive dance of me doing
some late 90s the early 2000s R&B I had
the right of soliloquy a lot of Hoops
for this Jetta did you when did you know
you're being scammed did you give her
money no but I gave her my info on my
phone number and he told him he was like
stop don't call them I just want you to
bite me get a BB it's bunny why can't
you baby bunny I'll be your hero
this jetta was once owned by Mike
McCready hold on what it's the
advertiser Mike McCready drove this
Jetta and it's up here my local Facebook
group from New Jersey from mere Teaneck
New Jersey because this car was kicked
in the rims by an angry any veter when
the turn was made while the walk signal
was going on crossing the street hey my
and pedestrians in the road to kayak I'm
drinking my wand across the street
trying to get to ukulele practice Lou
how much was she asking for in in eBay
1000 for a car I know seems like too
good to be true hi well it is it is it
was too good to be true I know you
bought eBay gift cards for somebody just
going to us on my way to the store all
right I'll see if these things exist
I'll buy him but I don't know speak to
the manager this CVS are these real yeah
this thing's real right now I'm just
gonna make sure a girl told me she'd
give me a car if I bought these four
biggest thousand dollars the guy goes
for a Jetta it's good deal
good deal I'd say do it I said you see
this on Facebook see your home - you go
your hometown weak on Facebook he's
unlocking the case with them but he goes
what all right I think I can say this
sooner your methamphetamines
so you've haven't so where you stand
right now I'm blocked in reported her
people boarded her and reported the
actual group hate group such a bitch
heads Lou the pearl uh why don't you try
to fight the guy who posted I who posted
it do you know where he lives
it's a woman and for her sister she had
a few mutual friends yeah whatever
sister was an on there but why don't you
do some investigation now and find out
who this was sure let's
exploit let's go to the tower in the
snatch why don't we do a bonfire
investigation take down this whole ring
justice alright while she sleeps for
release cockroach dinner here with
earwax would have them coated in earwax
yeah we'll shove them in pre pre-waxed
here's what we'll do we'll get all our
ear wax pulled and slather these roaches
in ear wax because keep out of your
house yeah your refrigerator let's keep
in your fridge right now you know I'm
doing a meal plan come on I got my
quinoa lamb you know I got my portions I
got my portion control so and then yeah
we'll take her down I love it I will
still want it
are you still looking for a Jetta or was
it a jeddak because it was $1,000 or
were you like finally like oh my god do
I get to keep the pink sunglasses
hanging from the rearview mirror can I
keep the class of 2008 forever the
scrunchie on the stereo
do I have to wash off the soap that says
r.i.p carmine forever young did I
mention that part the car is so cheap
because the her husband died oh not in
it Oh that'd be great cooked a lot he
od'd in the back yeah so his ghost is
gonna bother you his ghost is gonna
backseat drive is now if you're
wondering why is just too good of a deal
to be true because it is slightly
haunted by my
how are you were in the market for a
haunted Jetta changing the channels to
the music he likes he was into country
pop the fluid will be blood sometimes
that is him manipulating the car it will
break on the highway you'll put your air
conditioner on it'll come out hot every
the screams of the Damned will come
through your speakers yes once in a
while you're gonna push the button
you're gonna push the lever to squirt up
the windshield washer fluid and bees are
gonna shoot out if bees or blood that's
what we have in the fluid also know that
the car will pin in gas sometimes on a
highway while you're by a cop good news
though if it kills it's gonna seek out
your particular enemies yeah so it just
song somebody Christine King car yeah do
you think it is gonna run down your
enemies so that's cool so that is a
benefit also great gas mileage you'll
have to be there yeah I don't have to be
there the car leave at night you can
you're sleeping it's eliminating your
foes what was that you're saying what
happens if it gets into an accident
fixes itself yeah by the way there is
flesh underneath the oh god no this car
is uh-oh the car does bleed cartas bleed
because there are there is a ribcage
underneath there's a lot to explain I'm
basically if you buy you're buying as is
if you no one's gonna work on this car
if you nap in the car you will be woken
up by a heartbeat it is terrifying
because if anything happens to the
engine you are gonna have to go to some
sort of a warlock mechanic combo which I
have yet to see good luck they have one
of the benz dealership at Delaware
they're gonna have to drive all the way
up there for that there's one in Norwalk
Delaware also the real ittle south of
Wilmington the rearview mirror will show
you your dead relatives decomposed heads
up just in case you're looking to merge
and also the door lock Wiggles but one
Kay but that all that said okay and you
are cruising around my husband was a
very bad you're cruising around hat to
roof in a Volkswagen Jetta hey where you
going don't forget to watch the next
video stay tuned now for part two I've
always wanted to say this but click the
link is that a thing we're gonna do
click the link